Um, I don't.
I don't even know how to introduce this.
George Santos says he survived an assassination
attempt.
That is the latest.
Rachel MADDOW has surfaced video of an interview
that George Santos gave in Portuguese.
Okay, so the clip we're going to look at is
in Portuguese
with subtitles, and I'll pause momentarily.
You know, every once in a while to tell you
what's being said.
He claims he was the victim of an attempted
murder, that he survived and it led to him
being under police protection.
There is no evidence of this.
I should mention listen to this.
So at the top of the show, I went through
a long but definitely not exhaustive list
of the known lies of freshman Republican Congressman
George Santos of New York.
You're probably familiar with some of the
greatest hits by now, the volleyball star
and Wall Street fortune and all that stuff.
Right.
But here's something you have not heard before.
Did you know that Congressman George Santos
also claims he was the target of an assassination
attempt which required him being put under
official police protection?
Wow.
That is what Jorge Santos claimed last month
in an interview with a Brazilian podcast.
The podcast is called Radio Novello.
Presenter Forgive my pronunciation.
Radio Novello.
Presenter They shared this video from the
interview exclusively with us so you won't
see this anywhere else, but I want you to
see it in this interview.
Then Congressman elect George Santos is speaking
with the hosts in Portuguese.
So we have subtitled it.
He starts off talking about an alleged act
of vandalism, which he says was targeted at
him simply because he's a Republican.
But then in the midst of that, he says, oh,
also someone tried to murder him.
ENGINEER Judging from the actions of vandalism
and my video is interesting.
And you threw my face to defend John and I
was moving to bring a fly to do so.
So he says this happened in Florida and year
after year of party.
Memory, listening to what investigative journalism
you are facing, you apply to them.
So he says the vandalism was because he was
at a Republican Party.
Meeting in December.
It was moving to actually it was just, I think,
just a broken college villa.
I can't I'm just us tonight.
Okay.
So there he casually mentions I already suffered
an assassination attempt, which I survived.
Fatima Isadora, take the police escort to
the police.
Nothing shows sarcasm.
Yeah, very, very casual.
We had police protection, etc., etc..
We have already suffered an attempt on my
life.
An assassination attempt?
Yeah.
There was an assassination attempt to really
then Congressman elect George Santos did not
elaborate on his claim in the interview.
We have tonight reached out to Congressman
Santos, his office, to get more information
about him saying that he was the victim of
an attempted murder.
Yeah.
Getting New York police protection at his
home.
As a result, there ought to be a record of
that sort of thing if it happened.
We've inquired about this claim from him.
We have not heard back.
We do live in hope.
Mr. Santos did offer more detail about a different
act of violence he says was committed against
him.
In this interview with the same Brazilian
podcast.
He said he was the victim of a very, very,
very brazen mugging in the middle of the day,
in the
middle of New York, one of one of New York
City's busiest thoroughfares, very logical.
Injuring more very old gibberish, moving to
New Maywood, Lexington Avenue there, watching
what they were seeing, what they see for yourself,
Palpable noise on me and capital, which you
know what only it was I don't care.
I think.
Oh, my God.
He says.
Oh, God.
So first of all, he says, This was at fifth
and 55th.
Okay.
I don't understand how any such mugging could
take place at 15/55 in the middle of the day.
He volunteers before asking me any questions.
They weren't black.
They were even white, but they still even
white people.
These weren't even black folks.
And they still had the audacity to rob him
in broad daylight.
I felt bad, only bad only by Sullivan, only
supposed.
To know how they took his watch and his shoes
in the middle of the day on fifth and 55th.
He is free now.
Now lose Virginia.
And Tracy spoke in a Dodge about assignment
which kept fighting.
But I got AIG paying.
I'm okay.
I'll.
You'll figure something out.
Yeah.
Okay.
So I don't know that any of these things are
true, but these are extraordinary claims.
And it appears as though the lies simply will
not stop.
Voters are now furious with this guy.
He claims, I'm not hearing from anybody who
wants me to resign.
Let's talk about that next